non non Non
[Applaudissements]
Je sais que tu n'as pas besoin qu'on parle de toi
amour je sais
mais je ne supporte plus l'envie et
Je vais te dire que ton look me va bien
J'avais rêvé je sais avec qui si je
tu veux parler je vais te demander
Dis-moi que tu es seul et que personne ne te voit
comme moi dis moi que les ombres ne manquent pas
Nous sommes tous les deux ici, je ne jure pas oui
avec moi tu pars toujours avec un baiser tu le feras
réveille-toi et si tu tombes amoureux
mais je tombe amoureux de toi
[Musique]
je
et
quand je t'ai vu
et tout le monde est parti un moment et s'est arrêté
exister comme perdu dans le temps et
grâce à toi je vais savoir comment c'était
voix pour chanter je ne serai pas
[Musique]
vous demandera à nouveau
moi qui est sur celui que personne ne te voit
pendant qu'il le mange qu'il ne manque pas d'ombres et
même l'avocat a assuré que si avec moi
tu pars toujours avec un bisou tu le feras
réveille-toi ou si tu tombes amoureux je le jure
je dur
et
[Musique]
pour
et sûrement si tu pars toujours avec moi
avec un baiser tu te réveilleras et si tu
tu tombes amoureux j'ai
quoi de moins
en toi
[Musique]
Oui
[Applaudissements]